I did not expect to be playing this one
this is getting to be a pretty lengthy
stream pretty lengthy okay
anyhow 30 players now 10 seconds
remaining average rating 1789 time
position handicap 30 minutes craziness
here we go
Dima and let's go blue chicken blue
chicken can happen queenside castle
leads to game over for black whoa I'm
gonna take that pun and stop the bishop
exchange Bishop f6 don't know that I
push up I've discovered Knight d2 sneak
in to c4 maybe I want to do a three
Bishop here is that gonna be played
clean up watch over this square I have
this covered King side castle let's take
care do that if I did this there'd be a
queen there now I could castle and I'm
have a sneaky bishop moves I'm on the
Queen whoa dark squares get that night
actually night here here right here to
c5 him on the Queen now I'm on the
bishop Oh
just take this and then come over here I
want to get my rook to be one to be one
is the plan Oh pins pins pins no time
either about equal with time and I have
an advantage now a winning advantage
matin one or two
primo primo of here pre-move here right
here there down on tie back to
tournament oh man I'm so tired right now
I'm really tired
this is killing me gonna kill me ah no
Queen rook man that Simon took a lot out
of me I'm not used to doing that oh man
letting out on here oh I have no idea
what's gonna happen I feel a lot of
pieces following a lot are gonna follow
it's throw queen in the corner you could
do it you can do it just start
convincing yourself you could do it you
could do it you could do it you could
lose upon you could grab here and hit
him with a fork and they could grab your
Bishop with the check but it's gonna be
okay you're on the Queen you could still
do it you're on the Queen again they
missed it watch out for trickiness watch
out for trickiness knight here leading
to me and two or three I was gonna do it
no matter what me a quick win that's
what I needed
oh six six three two okay stop of those
points no Queen do you notice that the
these first three games
I could have blue chicken could have
clearly been a blue chicken see for know
don't you dare try to trade I'm not
welcome to it don't you dare try to open
up this position over here
h4 I'm gonna come over here keep it
closed don't be silly
take my pawn you know you want to do
that
push that night away ah let's try castle
now what am i down I'm down a minor
piece get this file up and up take that
pun I want the F file and take here kind
of block with my night I think now I
could come here I have this square
covered I'm on the night yes they missed
it but night here is still available
just get my other hook involved no that
would be me don't you dare lie here I
take and I take the bishop with for
kabuki let's come over here she's got to
me something juicy here let's go clean
take here recapture a night Forks tricky
I got Forks in a couple different ways
get the Queen for career ski but not
that one I didn't want to see that on
push whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa what's
happening I got to do this I think
that's an illegal move don't do that
nine seconds come on just go quick
you can do it you can do it why'd I do
that oh it's gonna be taken gonna take
here get out of sneaky stuff I just got
to go quick come on don't you dare give
up I should have taken that I should
have taken that they got that can give a
check time burners where the time
burners there's no time okay I just
realized that if I hold my breath I wake
up that's weird isn't it that's how it
worked just then I just held my breath
and then as soon as I caught my caught
my wind right there as soon as I got it
back I had a burst I felt a burst right
there
it felt a little burst what about this
and what about that and what about g4 in
an inch h5 and then h4 running four
touchdowns pushing pieces around opening
age files keep running run forest age
four run forest
grab a pod smash open the king
here we go we have an h-file do
something with it now hit this pond it's
weak isolated ponds look for homes right
here's a home he's being chased to home
grab a bishop get on the dark squares
but not so fast it'll be a pawn push
let's castle
let's take no no no I don't want to do
that I want to play bishop here
ah man they're being a pest
okay files are opening up I'll do this
no and they get my bishop here one day
one day right now right now is the day I
got this I'm on the pond right here King
F to know I could take that night it's a
pin rook takes pawn no I could just take
this rug what's happening kitchen sink
this is the kitchen sink line bishop
check um where's the mate let's just
take that night
this is winning I'm up I'm up with full
rook now rook checks step ladder step
ladder to me King here look here got the
Queen time is equal looking good okay
step ladder actually one into one - no
they resigned back to tournament 2019
1612 Jack and Jill is up there in place
- still very early on 22 minutes
remaining
okay let's go stay focused here stay
focused
you got a play against mr. Griffin mr.
Griffin as team black all right
83 h3 III you've seen it before if
you've been here before
you will keep seeing the same old
baloney because I have to avoid
exchanges and go after that King okay we
got the center locked tonight right here
just take them give me that g file okay
the ek I meant okay
oh that nights gonna kill me if he gets
to camp out on this square just take the
night that was a free piece that was a
free piece take free pieces haha just
take three pieces from now on free
pieces everywhere free piece if there
was a free piece that was it right there
you were looking right at it
okay let's regroup here stay focused now
get the King up you don't want to
castling over here these pawns are gonna
kill you let's hit that pun once there's
no like a breakthrough at that my King
has to run to the corner let's come to
the corner I want to watch out for that
c4 square is that is that gonna happen
it's happening I got to do this I want
my bishop here now right here save the
day bishop glue everything together save
the day pon push here don't you dare do
it let's do this first I have I have
nothing good here nothing good is
brewing
I have nothing here I have absolutely
nothing here I got to get over active in
this direction whoa what's going on with
this oh they don't have any time oh they
could do that they're gonna pin defend
defend pre move they're down on time
back to term in 30 29 24
I'm not gonna have Bishop puns okay I
don't have one bishop pun but I have the
F file if I play d5 I would have been
dead already
because the queen jack brutal avoid
those brutal moves okay I'm gonna keep
my knight away I'll go here okay I get
the F foul give me that light square
bishop would you give me that guy gave
me that guy I think bishop there would
have killed me I'd I'm so dead
I am so dead I'm a dead man take my
knight would you please I need help i
need help and it's nowhere to be found
nowhere to be found this help that I
need what about d6 my light-square
bishop would like to play the game whoa
but White has something to say about
that one something very serious I got to
do this and then pawn push I'm on the
Queen and I shut down the bishop and I
could play here next and I'm threatening
to take the knight how did I lose a lot
of that one I'm in trouble I got to take
care first and I got to defend this pawn
I have to give up my knight hold on to
d5 for dear life hold on to d5 Queen
trade where are you at that was a mouse
lip they meant to go there last time I
got the Queen's off hanging on d5 don't
go anywhere
not so fast get out of there rope okay
okay okay okay
Primo's Primo's go quick go go go go
grab that pine it was free grab that
free stuff grab that free stuff here
give a check and then play here hit a
pawn get this guy going get him going
again again right here grab a pawn
I got to do this I need to come over
here pawn push pawn push again pawn push
again I got a queen I got a queen I got
a queen can't be stopped no who's
running for the hills
now who's running for the hills King
position grab a bishop
grab a pawn give a check push a pawn
push another pun right here give a check
over here give a check right here give a
check grab a pawn
give a check here they're down the time
back to tournament 48 some Jack and
Jill's up there oh I was trying to just
be clever with Liz I'm a little like
some little playoff of Jack and Jill
there's got to be something there I feel
it if I wasn't so tired I think I'd come
up with that but I'm tired
in the meantime fish man is giving me
time to think about something clever for
Jack and Jill Jack and oh no hang on we
have on we have action over here fish
man has decided to play and as well just
move here just move quit trying to be
creative here silly little words G 493
Castle you've seen it you've seen it now
we can open stuff up here not so fast
though let's do this so I can protect
this and then play this my Knights dead
but what can you do what can you do
let's go king you know you could do it
get that night out of here Queen G 1 to
H 2 take that pond you know you want to
take them ah ok give me this defend I
got the dark squares dark squares it's
happening it's happening dark squares I
cannot deal with that night I just want
to take that night whoa whoa whoa come
over here before there's a disconnect
this is gonna be a check my king has to
come here come over here right here
otherwise bishop here skewers and stuff
Oh what do we have here I got to get the
Queen's off they don't have any time
let's give a check just for fun let's
take here let's defend stuff over here
please
they're down in time back to tournament
tie for first 56 56 47 46 those guys
with 47 to 46 are right up there right
up there
double those points moon - moon - okay I
could use a breather here give me some
water moon - what's going on elsewhere
Lancaster's in second with 56
I didn't even realized that tough guy
Lancaster Jack and Jill adonde vamos is
there as well I'm gonna get the W for
this but the points have not been
doubled and guess who drops to third in
a blink 56 I think if I win this I'm
getting plus 10 which will catapult me
back up to first 66 oh it's back and
forth back and forth five four three two
one and goose egg give me eight points
what's going on oh I only have 64 and
lancaster must have just won if we get
paired up I wonder what the it might
just be a regular bullet game I turned
out to be a regular bullet King maybe
one side will just have less time or
something where are you gonna go Queen
side wherever you go my Knights gonna
hunt you down it's gonna go here here
with my knight okay it's coming here now
let's take this Knight and then close up
the center I want my night to get here
please get that okay let's be sneaky
take that night
watch out for this break it's happening
no matter what oh boy oh boy I really
don't want to take that bishop maybe I
should have but I didn't clearly come on
hold the fort rook hold the fort you
could do it
hold that for get out of there Knight
okay I think a 4 and 9 a 5 is better get
out of there Knight break down the
center how much time do they have okay
keep that closed oh I could take the
bishop please don't miss it all right
please don't see it yes they didn't see
it got the bishop run run away scared
defend on the dark squares Castle
queenside Knights gonna come here on a
better play Knight here okay right here
I have to go in this direction right
here I just have to take there's Queen
takes bishop maybe no no no no no oh I'm
glad I saw that one get the Queen and
then look for me they're down on time 12
minutes and change remaining where does
that mean check check and then main just
move back to tournament back to
tournament where we yeah 98 8277
Lancaster in first I'm ready to play the
Sicilian with all the coffee I was ready
to just play the Sicilian - the Queen
rook ok the points have been doubled
that's what I need and they need to win
quickly I need a boost can I get a boost
give me that boost give me gave me gave
me the boost 97 98 here um let's try
this instead kick that night around
get out of there Knight maybe this stop
the my Knight wants to get to this
square I just move oh I can't move it's
pinned that's why I wasn't moving
get out of there Queen I want to move
I want to move that night get out of
there Queen I get this no I can't I
don't want the position to open up too
much clock situation oh well is it
opening up if I've ever seen it open it
up it's opening up right now all right
let's do this
I'm on this pond recapture here Bishop
here night here f6 is week g3 I want to
is where I want to be oh I could just
take it takes Knight pawn takes let's
get my other night involved night here
oh boy got made threats come on defend
clean get this pot out of here I have my
knight defending but I can't really rely
upon that he's got to go 14 seconds oh
no no no that was a mouse limp
I promise it was give me a back give me
back and I had to take back there's no
tape back button wait wait it's my move
it's my move what happened just there
what happened do they move I missed it I
missed what their move was hit the Queen
they're going after my queen
oh I'm down that time I lost track of
whose move it was oh man not the first
time I've done that either oh man how
brutal is that don't you dare lose track
of time oh you lost track of whose move
it was I think I mouse slipped and then
my Pont was in a pre movin thing I can't
explain it
oh I just want to cry right about now
yeah I just want to cry I need a good
cry yeah what can you do you can't come
back from this can you here we go
you knew was happening you knew I was
gonna follow up with this didn't you you
knew it would happen like this where I
would start giving myself a pep talk ah
pep talk everybody needs a pep talk
every now and then got this pun don't
end up in a fork got this it's very
scary over here
oh very scary ha ha I need help
I need help you're gonna be perpetual
please say no no I only have 15 seconds
it's me for petrol at least whoa oh that
was a blunder hang on there's hope they
resigned back to tournament eight
minutes eight minutes eight minutes they
resigned right there that's exactly what
I needed a boost a boost I have I have a
glimmer of hope you gotta go flawless if
you're gonna do this you got to do this
flawless from here I know if you have
any hope no don't try to open stuff up
don't even try it
watch out for the sneaky pawn push it's
gonna happen
it's happening
you know what a pain okay come over here
oh I didn't want to do it but I have to
do it okay can I get in
stop it okay no I could take that penny
good I could take that and then run back
33 tics okay you could take this pot I
think take here you know you want to do
with the night whoa it's a dead night I
got the dead night dad this pawn pawn
push I got the night over here now let's
hit a rock and then pawn push just one
square one square tricky tricky tricky
to get out of my Knight wants to be on
this square right here ah this is this
is stinging right here wait a second I
have something sneaky up my sleeve this
works I got me I got me
I don't know whatever I don't know where
the rook I don't know where boom eight
120 148 134 120
I'm reenergized somehow somehow 154 148
oh this is the top dog this is the top
dog come on you got to get this you
could do it you could do it you could do
it f7 I'm down two pawns this guy ah man
man get over here down two pawns don't
you dare try and get my clean let's try
it again are we going for a drum no I
don't want one I want to win should
taking it I should have taken it come
over here don't try to get my light
square bishop I'm not having it let's
try it again we're gonna dance again
uh-huh I'll come back there no let's try
it again we're having fun I'm gonna go
here again no repetition for you no soup
for you I got a pine I got another pine
it's crumbling grab a night they must be
nervous
let's take here central pawn push
I got open files my rooks are standing
pretty
they're standing pretty I'm coming with
Queen g3 again you can't avoid that
sneaky maid sneaky mates h7 be scared be
very scared get a knight there's got to
be something oh I think I have something
up my sleeve let's play here Queen takes
their get out of their time situation
where we at take the Queen take free
Queens take free Queens Queen takes
tricky stuff happening tricky stuff
uh-oh
check grab here do anything they're down
on time they don't have any time then I
mean time back to tournament I got 20 oh
I have to get that guy 152 168 four
minutes and change fish man got a battle
the fish man I need one quick when you
sign her and I'm back into it somehow
somehow after that silly silly silly
loss ah let's go keep track of whose
move it is back to the chess 101 move it
move if it's your move
wow wow move it's if it's your move you
got to move it's as simple as that
get that night out of there keep going
pawns you can do it open this up let's
roll keep it closed over here H 4 H 3 H
4 H to take a free rook maybe actually I
like my bishop too much I'm gonna do
this get this take it take it take it
with check with check move my knight get
my queen over on H 2 coming up coming up
why'd I do it with my rook I don't know
they can't take I think it leads to me
check check and then is this next one
mate the King is running for the hills
oh there's a defense right here is
Bishop gonna block darn it
okay I got I got a time edge i'm on the
rook around that let's take this pawn go
go go
time time time three minutes and change
over here let's back up anything
anything anything at all grab here
checks get rid of this Knight
they're down in time back to term at 161
sit 178 162 162 lose and I need to win
two more games Oh am I gonna get paired
up with that guy two minutes 45 seconds
we're only gonna get one Maureen for
sure for sure
is this an odd mover wait a second no
it's a mover uh let's get my hopes up
thinking I was gonna get a win in just
one minute
I'm gonna get in this move oh it's not
happening
towards the center this move I still
want to get in uh why don't I play like
it's a regular chess game over here this
I get in b5 maybe let's let's guard this
square block it up here
smooth why am I not moving quick enough
pawn push right here I guess and do this
and then take with my F pawn take with
my half-pint give me the F file please
man
alright you know take like this man this
is tough
I need something something to work with
here
something to work with where are you at
mm there's gonna be Queen check or
something no let's do this another rook
get this in so I could play g4 without
this falling palm push again King
position 30 seconds that's a good move
that's a good move very nice very nice
very nice well done let's go I have to
give up my light skirt under my darks my
light square bishop yeah sure
let's get these pawns going I need rooks
genius guy a quick resigner he's gonna
quick resign double the points or resign
resign
yeah series i/o 200 I'm in second I need
another quick resigner 20 22 18 is in
first 18 6
18 16 15 14 13 are they gonna pair me up
a me up pick me up
keep me in second if anything quick
resign quick resign Maine where's the
Maine
where's the Maine I need Maine get over
here Bishop again third muster just one
Oh what can you do huh I'll take the
confetti and run with it
and let me close - OH - seventy oh there
wasn't a flawless I guess uh there was a
little slip-up there seventeen sixteen
sixteen seventeen
nobody was perfect alright good games Oh
BAM alrighty